خلال 20 دقيقه اجهز الشاب محمد صوف من
قريه حارس على ثلاثه مستوطنين واصاب اثنين
اخرين بجروح في محيط المستوطنه ارئيل
المقامه على اراضي محافظه سلفيت بالضفه
الغربيه
في ثلاثه مواقع قرب المدخل الرئيسي
للمنطقه الصناعيه في المستوطنه ومحطه
وقوده ثم استولى على مركبا لينفذ بها
عمليه دهس قبل اطلاق النار عليه من احد
جنود الاحتلال ومستوطنين وقتله في المكان
تعزيزات امنيه كبيره وصلت المنطقه وشرعت
في البحث عن مشتبه اخر قدم له المساعده
وفق بيان الجيش الذي وصف العمليه بالخطيره
الاوساط السياسيه الاسرائيليه الرسميه
اكدت ان اجهزتها الامنيه ماضيه في محاربه
مواصفاته بالارهاب دون هواده لحمايه
مواطنها
الاخيره نجحنا في منع عمليات كثيره
وسنواصل مبادره والعمل المسؤوليه مهنيه
وسنقتص من كل ما يحاول المشاركه في عمليه
الارهابيه وسنعمل كل ما يمكن لمنع المساسي
بمواطنه اسرائيل
قوات كبيره من جيش الاحتلال اقتحمت مسقط
راس الشهيد محمد صوفي قريه حارسه ودهمت
منزله واجرت تحقيقات مع افراد عائلتها
بينما انتشر مستوطنون على مفترقات الطرق
الالتفافيه للاعتداء على فلسطينيين
ومركباتهم كل هذا جعل هناك دوافع لدى
الجيل الفلسطيني للعمليات الفرديه من اجل
الرد على المستوطنين وقف اعتداءاتهم هذا
لن يتوقف ما دام هناك احتلال وما هناك
مستوطنين
احدثه في سلسله هجمات نفذها فلسطينيون
وتاتي رغم حاله تاهب امنيه اسرائيليه قسوه
في وقت يصاعد فيه الاحتلال مداهماته
واعتقالاته وعمليه القتل
ففي بلده بيت عوا جنوبي الخليل شيع
الاهالي جثمان فتاه استشهدت برصاص
الاحتلال فجر الاثنين في بلده بيتونيا
قضاء رام الله قوات الاحتلال وصلت
اقتحامها مدنا وبلدات في الضفه الغربيه
بما فيها القدس المحتله واعتقلت عددا من
الفلسطينيين وصادرت اسلحه وذخائر واموالا
في سياق ما تعرف بحمله الكاسر الامواج
الراميه لملاحقه المطلوبين لديها سمير ابو
شمالي الجزيره سلفيت فلسطين